[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Flair's big big time place just here oh  my goodness give me the hot sauce zach  lavine and that's with a good defender  on him  if rumbles of the same spot here it is  again  [Applause]  and again the funny thing about this is  it said if you're Indiana the other way  but it because he was a little late with  turning around he was able to make that  play on Oladipo of time up the dark  fetch dunks oh he was late getting over  early for the poster now he comes back  and they're already headed the other way  but he because he was a little late  turning around he was able to make that  play on Oladipo of time up  [Music]  [Applause]  I mean they get to switch cuz miles  that's a good pick and you can say  market  [Applause]  and then lowry legend continues to grow  and develop bang bang bang  [Applause]  oh my goodness hey daddy look at Chris  Dunn's face  wheel away they get it oh man oh my god  sake y'all my if he hit this oh my